[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life
where we sit through philosophy to find
practical advice that you can use in
your everyday life
hi i'm dan hayes and i'm joined by my
co-host dr greg
seidler we are talking today about
so today we're doing something a little
bit different it's episode number 20
and we're labeling it episode 20
extravaganza
so we're going to talk about the show
it's a little bit meta
i guess you could say all right we're
going to talk about how we got started
with this the idea
of the show we've also solicited some
questions
from viewers and we've got quite a few
of those
lined up so if you had to sum it up in
one phrase how how would you sum this up
we hit a
milestone or it's definitely a milestone
um it is a one of those silver linings
on kobit
oh right so we're going to talk a bit
about
how we converted from
an in studio show to what you're hearing
right now and if you're watching this
what you're
what you're seeing there's a quite a
story to be told there
before we do that though something we've
been meaning to do for quite a long time
you know this this is hosted on
riverwest radio 104.1
fm lp milwaukee and we wanted to put in
a pitch for
people ought to donate you know it's
it's a it's a great thing to do
community radio really matters you get
to hear voices that you
ordinarily wouldn't hear in commercial
radio and so we've been meaning to do
this for quite a while but we kept on
uh getting too excited about the stuff
that we were talking about to get that
pitch in there
right and and they run a really great
tight little ship over there there
um all the new hosts get a
a really comprehensive rundown of all
the do's and don'ts and how to actually
you know run a radio show like it's like
boot camp uh nearly free for like all
those that want to
you know dip their toes into radio yeah
you know one of the things that they
stress that i remember from
our our orientation sessions was that
we're not just hosts
we're producers we're the people who
make sure that
all the different things that have to
happen with the show do
happen and so there's more agency and
more
autonomy there again something that's
really cool about
community radio i think and we're not
just you know these pretty faces and
voices to be
gawked at yeah i mean you might be
talking about me
like 20 years ago but
you're you're still young enough to be
able to to say that about yourself i
suppose
ah why thank you i was not
actually fishing for compliments
[Laughter]
so let's let's uh talk about some people
may be tuning in for the first time
what is this show basically about we
have the tagline of you know
sifting through philosophy finding
practical advice that's important
um what else what else should we say
about that
well it's kind of like there's a
difference between
academic philosophy as well as or and
the
in the more practical philosophy of
philosophy as a way of life and so
you know there's uh academic philosophy
of like doing a philosophy of like
you know taking a particular thought or
idea
and trying to just dissect it and um
and then you know making a good reasoned
and logical
arguments in order to support uh your
position or
to refute another's position uh but
that is this kind of thing that's so
removed from
actually everyday life and we have this
really
vast uh history of
philosophers you know looking at what
actually makes
a good life and what what are these
things that result in
one's own happiness and an attainment of
a flourishing life and
uh you know from you know all the way
from socrates up to
you know a lot of like utilitarians and
there's like still
moderns that are talking about this but
it really has gone out of vogue to a
certain extent
and so our idea or the the main idea for
this
radio show is to you know try to say hey
look
there's all these people that have
thought about these really useful things
we can actually use these in our
everyday life they might work for you
they might not but
uh the very least you should be
given the opportunity to try them yeah i
think so there's a lot of really good
points there
and one of the last ones about not
everything working for every person
i think sometimes people view that as
a problem but it really makes sense if
human nature
is complicated and we human beings are
super complicated
because we're not just one generic you
know
nature like we're stamped you know like
a bunch of robots or something but each
of us develops on our own
it would make sense that some practices
or techniques or insights are going to
be more applicable for
some people and less applicable for
others and i think a lot of people when
they hear philosophy they
they imagine it's going to be something
totally abstract and general
and it should apply across the board to
everybody or it's no good and
you know there's there's a long history
and philosophy
of thinking about how to apply it
in this it's not totally particular it's
not
totally general it's kind of in this
middle ground where you can say
oh you're this kind of person or you're
struggling with this kind of problem
this might be helpful for you or try to
supplement it with with this
sort of technique rather than a one size
fits
fits all approach and so there's a long
tradition of that
in philosophy as dan was just saying
understood as a way of life philosophy
used in ancient times in medieval and
early modern times for a kind of therapy
a working on uh they called it the soul
we could we could call it the mind or
the the psyche if you want
psyches just soul and greek or uh
personality
whatever it is that you you wanna call
it
yeah and we can see this uh kind of
processed into a lot of the more
um recent uh things in vogue and
uh psychology you know both if you go
from the buddhist tradition a lot of the
uh meditative things have been found
into
mindfulness you know uh therapies as
well as
stoicism is one of the basis for
accommodative behavioral therapy um and
erica as well as cognitive emotive
behavioral therapy
and there's definitely things that are
being systematized into like okay
this is something that can very well
be applied in a very therapeutic manner
but it's not like
these are only for those people that
really need therapy there are
general things that can be applied in
one's everyday life
yeah there's a greater scope to it you
could say
there's also something i'm going to
bring up something from
donald robertson that he said in a
conversation
a while back he remarked that
cognitive behavior therapy you know did
come out of stoicism
as did you know the earlier rational
motive behavior therapy
you could say the whole cognitive
revolution in some respect is
indebted to stoic philosophy and
you know albert ellis wrote books and
there's there's
these other people associated with
cognitive behavior therapy that
wrote books like you know the feeling
good that you see
in every used bookstore and and donald
said something really
interesting which was that generally
people read their way through one of
these books
and then they never reread it again
they'll read reread
portions of it so like beck's you know
feeling good if you're
struggling with anger okay you'll read
that chapter but you're not going to
read the whole thing again
whereas with stoic philosophy people
will
get seneca's letters and they'll read
through the whole thing
and then they'll do it again and then
they'll do it again and they'll keep
doing it
because there's something more there
there's something this is his take as a
cognitive behavior therapist
there's something more substantive
something more systematic there
that you just can't get out of i guess
you could call the manuals
for for how to retune yourself you know
and and same thing with marcus aurelius
people will reread the meditations over
and over again or epictetus discourses
and i think he's right about that and i
think we can say that about all sorts of
other classics you know
people will reread nietzsche's uh birth
of tragedy even though nietzsche
you know attacked it later on and say ah
it's a juvenile work people will reread
that
over and over again or descartes
meditations or
you know pick whoever you like because
there's something there
that it adds a new value each time that
you
you do re-read it and a lot of times
these values are things that can
directly
affect our life or help us understand
who we are
it's amazing the way that when we frame
things
how that allows us to
absorb that information well and like
just a manual
is yeah it's great for looking up a very
specific thing
but if you really want to internalize
something you know make a story out of
it
there's a lot of yeah mnemonic devices
about like
how do you remember like eight different
totally disassociated things well you
make them part of a story and all of a
sudden you can like say that
the the red rocket uh had a washing
machine inside it in which
uh albert einstein um threw
his top hat you know like none of these
things are
independently connected but once you
weave them together in a story
you can like hold on to them to grok
them to
yeah potentially make them your own just
a little bit easier
yeah that's true and and with with those
kind of writings i mean
when you read the the popular self-help
stuff it is addressed to you
as the audience member but it's not
addressed to you in the same way that
like seneca's letters are
or descartes meditations is you know
even when we're like like sitting in on
somebody else's conversation
we feel like we're either we're you know
like a bystander or maybe
you know a voyeur who shouldn't be
listening to it or something
um or we feel like we've been invited
into the conversation
and um you know we get to talk with
people of good will
and some significant intellects
who've devoted a lot of thought to
issues that we might we might care about
maybe that's why dialogues are so
compelling as they form
you know this is again totally off topic
we really got to jump into talking about
the show
we're kind of doing the show rather than
yeah about it um
we're not doing the meta yeah i had a
student today and i was having a
conversation
with him and this is after the class is
over so obviously our conversation was
digital we're using a google meet to do
this
and i was following up with him about
the class
and he brought up that we had these
online class sessions
and he said that the things that he
liked the most about it wasn't just when
we're like
looking directly at some issue or topic
in philosophy it was an intro to
philosophy class
he said he really liked the parts where
it kind of veered off and turned into
dialogue
about stuff that was connected to what
we were
studying but wasn't directly connected
to it and
and i think i decided talking with him
in that conversation
i said you know for my fall classes i'm
going to build in
some some time that's just like that now
it's a risk because what if nobody talks
but i think we do need some space for
that
more open-ended discussion where you get
to
see what other people think and maybe
you
maybe challenge them or maybe you
reinforce what they're saying or maybe
you just like you know go off on a
tangent yourself
i think we we need that as as people
right so so going back to our position
here
like how did the show get started well
you can you can
tell the story you were really the
catalyst for that so
yeah so um greg leads the stoke
fellowship
at least the the monthly meetings um and
after that's
now right yeah you're actually are you
still needing something
ah but like the monthly meeting is still
your
domain for the most part but we we met
up
before um when we could actually meet up
and
um at the library and afterwards uh this
guy was like hey is there something you
want to kind of collab on
and um came down to
i knew about riverwest radio and we like
started talking about that and
um you had already done something with
them
earlier with zob right you had they'd
had you on for
yeah i'd go on a couple shows like as a
guest
for interviews
and and i'd been aware of it because i
lived in
the riverwest neighborhood for exactly a
decade um
and and hung out and zobb's tv zob is
the the
owner of the building and the head of
the the radio
station at least partly co with um
with martin martin thank you
and uh so we
went on and they're having it was the
end of the year so they have been a fun
drive
and so we went on to
uh help out and do some uh
holidays yeah and so it's actually if
you go to the our podcast it's
it's the very first thing in our feed is
a
pre wisdom for life wisdom for life yeah
it was wisdom for life before we even
had
a real idea for the show we were just
doing the stuff that we normally do
in wisdom for life yeah and so that was
uh
what uh it's good it's giving good
that's right yeah yeah tied in with the
holiday season
and donations and yeah that's true
there was a lot of synergy in that topic
there yeah and that was that was kind of
fun because um
well martin was banning the uh the sound
thing right so we didn't have to worry
about that we just sat you know
uh chit-chatting about all of our ideas
um and then we decided let's do a show
right so we gets uh like
when's the next time that we can do the
orientation because you had to do the
orientation before you were
allowed to basically touch anything um
and rightly so i think oh yeah yeah
we're sitting here and we're we're
drinking our liquids and
that would be a no-no yeah yeah unless
that was like a water bottle with like a
yeah no just no keep them away from all
the electronics there
this is way too expensive um it's not
expensive you don't need to go there
at all um and
it was it was just a really good time
and we we did our first show and it
sucked a little bit but it was okay
because it didn't totally suck
yeah i mean we're what are they saying
that not just getting our feet wet but
sort of like if we want to use a feet
metaphor
figuring out how to stand on the ground
right or i
sort of lost the train in the metaphor
but but yeah so
we decided uh we would do a show
and um when did we when did we do the it
was in february right that we did the
uh the orientations we had to come in on
the weekends
yeah and then was it really early march
that we started doing
our first episodes you know i'm not sure
if it was
late february or early march um
you said that we've been doing it for
roughly six months and i was kind of
surprised
when when i saw you right then and then
i thought yeah actually it probably is
close to six months now
because i forgot how late in the year we
are so
yeah as well as like if you go back to
that december
uh show which was oh yeah i guess in
that case we've been doing
i mean if that counts then we've been
doing the show
for eight months
now and we did it every other week for a
while
that's right right yeah we we only got
two episodes in and something kind of
funny
happened i mean not funny in the grand
scheme of things because cobit is not a
laughing matter
but um we showed up for our second
episode we had all this stuff plotted
out and you know planned out we were
at the fuel which was next door which
now i guess is closing for
you know ever i don't know it's it you
know
who knows with with pandemic times but
uh we we
went in the station and i was kind of
surprised that they locked the door
after us i don't know if you noticed
that and yeah
uh i thought well okay maybe it's just
the time or something like that because
we were doing
five o'clock at that time right five
o'clock on fridays
and we did a very premium spot yeah well
actually it's great
when people are actually driving oh yeah
but um so we did our show and it went it
went
good you know you can hear it online if
you want to
and then uh i don't remember if it was
average martin but one of them came up
to him and said oh you know the
station's closed
right you know you got the email we were
like we didn't know
so we we ended up being the last
in-person
show uh where people are actually
sitting at the mics and all of that sort
of stuff and then then we had to figure
well what are we going to do
well also uh we also were the reason
that we didn't get the email is that we
were such a new show
at the time that we had been um
not fully integrated into the email list
and so
the the email had gone out i just
totally it would
write by us without us knowing yeah into
the ether it went to us
and that show was focused on fear and
worries about
the pandemic that nobody knew or you
know how big it was going to get
right right and yeah yeah
we tried to make our stuff rather you
know insular and not
totally topical to the times but you
know there's there's a lot
that is rather evergreen that is still
very relevant if we're talking about
philosophy as a way of life
yeah that's the cool thing about
philosophy even when you're applying it
you can take the applications and then
move them somewhere else and you know
this isn't going to be the last
disease or pandemic that we we face so
yeah i've been you know having some
light reading of uh camus the plague
yeah and it's like oh look that happened
and that happened and that happened and
they're like
you know we've seen this before i'm like
and we'll see it again
yeah it's quite a popular book now yeah
we should probably
at some point in time do something about
that on one of the shows
you know yeah maybe maybe pandemic
literature
yes what we can learn from it that might
be an interesting thing
so you know now we're on the air
but obviously we haven't been able to go
to the station
uh since the second episode so that's
counting this episode um 18 episodes
where
we're doing it in a different way yeah
and like
we you had your gopro and so
uh for the first two episodes we have
gopro footage from us in studio
and then the next two episodes i think
we don't have any video
because the recording just wasn't
working right
right i think i forgot to record one
time
and there was another time where it just
didn't come out right or something
so we're what we're using for those who
are kind of you know interested in the
geekery of this
we're using zoom and that's how we
record the video that's how dan and i
can both see each other and have some
sort of rapport
you know we're not sitting across from
each other in a station where
we're looking at our images
mediated electronically and then each of
us is using audacity which is free
software that you can
you can get's really good for recording
things
and we take those those recordings
you know dan sends me the one from his
end and we clean them up a bit
and then we put them together and add
the show music that scott drewley
gave us early on uh real before we
started the show right we commissioned
him to do that
he's a good friend so he was willing to
create a kind of joe satriana
satriani-esque kind of track for us
and that's what we do now each each week
we
we've only had i think one week where we
didn't meet i think because i was sick
and
we've been churning away and
addressing topics each week and um
it's now i think maybe at first
were you were you less comfortable at
the start
i know i was with oh yeah doing things
like at the radio show or just
in the new way with the video and
yeah um it was
there's less dials here than at the
radio show so that was
one benefit i think the two shows that
we did it you did the sound board
right yes i think i did i didn't have to
i think you were supposed to the next
one but then that's right
i got out of it we're probably gonna
have to be retrained
when we actually go back to oh yeah oh
yeah
but and one of the things is
looking like because beforehand we are
totally live and now we're not and so if
there's
minor flubs we can edit them and so
there's only been a few times but it's
like
that one little it's like a safety net
of like oh
i said the wrong word should not say
that word on the air we don't actually
have a real delay where we can like
bleep stuff
out or anything like that so yeah
here here we here we can um and actually
in the editing because we usually go a
little bit longer than we're supposed to
uh if there's a long pause i'll i'll
like trim that
out you know so so what we're doing here
is
it's not quite a podcast although we
haven't established is a podcast too
um it's it you know it is radio
because it's being played on on the
radio um both locally and worldwide
streaming
um so it's kind of a hybrid thing really
yeah and i think it works quite well for
what we're doing
yeah yeah yeah that's that's that's
something kind of interesting to think
about it
might not work for every single topic
um that's out there it works good for
our stuff yeah
so one of the things that i thought we
would talk about is
what we've learned or things that we've
uh
changed over over the course of this how
it's how it's perhaps changed us
in some ways i mean we're not you know
we're not walking down the street
because obviously we're not walking down
any streets most of the time
and people coming up to say oh you're
the wisdom for life
people or anything like that
but it you know it's it's getting some
traction and i think that's kind of cool
yeah there's you know a decent amount of
people on youtube as well as that
download the
uh podcast rather regularly um yeah it's
it's nice to see that someone is finding
some use out of this
you know so that little thing that we do
that's one of the things that
i wouldn't say it's like a total
i never knew any of this before sort of
learning thing
it's more like a confirmation i i knew
and you knew too that there's a big
hunger out there for
you could call it substantive engagement
with ideas right
something that that can reach the
ordinary person so it's not being
presented in a very jargony academic way
but still has some rigor to it so it's
not just you know
fluff or or you know doing doing
that middle ground exactly which is a
tough tough
place to reach i think for for a lot of
people so
you could call this kind of a proof of
concept you know
not only do we know that you and i can
like do this
and make it work you know week after
week after week
but we know that people will listen and
we know that people will respond
and share it and be interested in it
it's not the first philosophy radio show
obviously
um but it's it's uh i don't know of any
other ones in the midwest
and and i'm aware of quite a few
like philosophy podcasts and like some
are even from the bbc and whatnot but
they're
they're most of them are very academic
minded of like
like these are the arguments and this
person has this position this person has
his position
and let's you know argue those positions
which is
like it's interesting but it's not like
how can you
make one's life better by knowing these
things yeah
that's true there's there's a there's a
lack
of of that out there um which this is
remedying hopefully for
people so um
what i mean what else have we learned
you know there's the whole technical
aspect of it i
i'm i'm still not like a whiz on
all of these platforms necessarily but
we we had to learn them
and that was always nice to learn
something new so
you know some new techniques and stretch
a bit i mean you're more of a tech
person
by by vocation than i am so i think it
was probably
maybe less of a stretch for you yeah
even though
you're definitely a much more the uh
social media maven i've uh
for the most part has screwed my uh
want to be on there so i i try to not
it's interesting i'm like man like i've
got a degree in computer science i work
in tech
and i try to use
social media as smallest amount as
possible
versus those out there and maybe it's
just because i'm so close to it that i
know
that could be how the sausage is made
and so i don't want to be there anymore
you know you understand the algorithms
better than the rest of us do you know
yeah unfortunately that
i mean there could be something to that
that the whole sausage being made
metaphor
when you're when you're that close to
what's going on maybe
it loses this charm well as part of it i
think is
uh just the the psychological benefits
of
not like constantly being bombarded both
with advertisement but also with
um yeah the idea of like these perfect
lives that all these people are around
you
and we don't have a good way to
map on our usual way that we interact
with those people close to us
to you know a thousand friends you can't
be close to a thousand people and have
meaningful relationships with a thousand
people
or or compare your life to a thousand
people because
you're gonna see a thousand people's
best days and none of their worst ones
and you're just going to
in a comparison feel
[Music]
really bad about yourself and i was
laughing because i was thinking
he's talking about instagram and maybe
facebook to a certain extent
i spend a lot more time on twitter than
i do facebook and i don't do instagram
uh and i think you do read it right so
and ready yes it's kind of like that
facebook instagram those are the places
for like you know taking the picture in
front of the sunflower field and using
all the filters and stuff like that
and i think there's some people that do
do that on twitter but for the most
part twitter is a lot closer to the
ground
let's say you know um people are
complaining about their lives and
yelling at each other it's sort of like
i heard the
you know clean wonderful beautiful place
with all these
calm people you know in their ethereal
gowns and stuff like that
down to like the you know it when they
had that show welcome back hot or back
in the 70s
the sweat hogs were what they called
those
those guys in mr cotter's class and i
think twitter is kind of like that
certainly it is for me and i and that's
i kind of like that
so i i um i spend more time there than i
do
on facebook yeah
uh and i guess with
both twitter and reddit you i really
think you need to curate it otherwise
you're just going to be
yeah stuck in the middle of the
cacophony of a thousand
angry voices and that's not really
helpful for
substantive conversation either yeah
it'll certainly give you a skewed
picture of the world and how awful it is
if you if you don't do it you know
so what are what are some things that
you've learned
uh through this process i mean some
technical things
yeah some technical things um like going
through the topics that we do like we
choose our topics and then we
kind of like okay i know a bit about
this but i should also go back and like
look at my sources and reread some
things
and so i guess one of the earliest ones
was or not the earliest ones
recent one was our episode on accracia
and i hadn't will right yes weakness of
will and so i had a really strong
affinity to the people do bad things
because they uh have misunderstood what
the good is they've they've said oh this
thing that we can
define is bad and they think it's good
at the time so like
i'm going to uh hold up this liquor
store
because i i want the money because you
know the money is good
even though that that action is
definitely a bad action
and uh
and reading into the gracia much more is
like okay there are still a lot of
people that have that
misconstruction and this application of
the good to the bad
but there's also people that just like
through apathy and lots of other reasons
just don't do the right thing even
though it's right there in front of them
yeah they or they know that it's the
wrong thing and they're going to do it
anyway
yeah it's
like you said humans are so good are you
happier knowing that that often is the
case or would you prefer
to be back thinking well no people i i
would prefer to
have a representation of reality that is
closer to reality
yeah it's interesting um descartes
raises that question
at a couple different points in his
works
about you know one one possibility would
be
it would be nice to like think
everything goes well
and the world is arranged you know for
the best and all that
all sorts of beautiful um
let's call them dreams or or um
falsehoods not to not to you know
put too fine a point on it they're
believing things that aren't the case
and and being happy because of that
descartes says
well truth itself is as a good
and if you know if you even suspect that
like you're
you're being deceived about it you're
not really gonna be that happy with it
he's got this great metaphor at the the
end of uh
meditation one where he talks about
being like a servant whose life sucks
it's terrible and he's dreaming but he's
having the kind of dream where he
you kind of know that you're dreaming
maybe because he realizes that you know
there's a big discrepancy between this
and he knows that he's going to
have to wake up really soon but he tries
to extend the dream as long as possible
so that he can enjoy what's what's in
the dream knowing it's false
you know and he says maybe that's that's
um
the case that that some of us are in uh
but you know we we eventually have to
face
things as they are at least as as closer
to how they are
right i feel like there's there's a
place for fantasy
and so it has a a momentary escape kind
of
an uh an inner citadel of a quiet and
contemplative space
yeah um but uh that is
only a respite and you know once once
you've you know
replenished yourself one needs to go
back and
actually deal with it what is the real
you know the very first work of science
fiction in the west and
maybe there's earlier works in in other
areas
uh is by it's called the true history
and it's full of lies
and it's by um lucian of samson
right some of samoa uh i always get the
the name mixed up
and he begins it with this preface where
he says
i'm writing this and it's full of lies
and i'm writing it to provide relaxation
for people who spend their time
doing difficult intellectual work right
just to let yourself unwind
just just like how you know um
bodybuilders and wrestlers and people
who are always doing things with their
body they need to have some down time
too
this is my downtime book for you and so
he
effectively invents the science fiction
genre
you know millennia before the big boom
in science fiction
with a story of a trip to the moon and
interstellar warfare
and stuff like that just to allow us to
uh relax a bit you know
and fantasy so
uh do you have anything that you learned
well like i said you know some some of
the platform things
um what can be done how to
um think about you know
presentation of this on the radio
so far i haven't had to bleep anything
out
so but you know you never know um
what else uh i would say that there's
there's quite a few things where
it's been because of like um
our conversations or responses of people
to the show
afterwards so i was like oh okay yeah
there's a point to that
that way of looking at things you know
so it's more of a like expanding
the uh the um
horizons you could say adding
new voices in there um that's what i
would say i
i've learned the most again too the
proof of concept is this actually people
will listen to this
um you never really know until you try
it out
right so we got some questions from our
viewers
yeah so um let's read the first one
it's kind of a long one so it says i've
been struggling i've been trying to use
stoic principles in my life
it's very valuable most of the time one
thing i struggle with is motivation
stoics say go and do things which
concern only four virtues and don't care
about anything else
however for me it's more complicated
than that if i want to get a promotion
of some kind of status which would
enable me to do good things
like feed clothe my children wife help
my parents or other people
and there's obstacles on the way then i
say to myself the thing i want to
accomplish is
indifferent and i get tranquility
however i don't get as much motivation
as i would being
super anxious about it and would
probably work a lot harder to get it if
i was stressed by it
how could i have the same level of
motivation if i was under stress
together with being calm and rational
so that's a good question fair fair
question right
yeah uh so like this is
kind of the the common stoic trap
uh that many people fall into when they
go into this it's very similar that
happens within
the buddhist tradition as well of
feeling you know getting
like rid of dukkha or suffering
by um removing your dependence on things
and and part of this is like the
indifference are like the the outcomes
but like your actions
in doing these things are the things
that are actually important that have
value and part of this whole thing is
that
we it's it's a reorientation
away from this you know uh
anxious and stressed uh motivation
factor
into cultivating a internal locus of
control or
center of control that is
that desires doing the good and so
it's like you work on saying like what
are the things that i actually desire
here and trying to orient yourself to
that and it's going to take work you
know
they say anger is a great motivator but
also
relieves you to potentially really
negative bad ends and so you got to be
careful in how that is applied
yeah that's a that's a great answer i
would i would say as well that
you know it is a beginner's mistake in
stoicism
because when you study stoicism you find
out that the four
virtues and those are wisdom justice
temperance and courage
those don't just like sit in in a person
all by themselves
they apply to things in the world and
they apply to indifference so we want to
use
things that are indifferent wisely
and justly and prudently and
courageously
and so you know the motivation can be to
do so
virtuously right to you know
so let's take money for example the
stoics don't say oh money doesn't matter
so just like throw it all away or burn
it up or
any you know they they think you ought
to be prudent with your money it's just
that
you shouldn't value that above say being
virtuous
or other things that really matter so
so you can have the motivation without
being
anxious all the time and
it's too bad you know i mean if you
think about people who
feel that they need to make themselves
feel bad
in order to get something good done
that's a that's a crappy way to live you
know wouldn't it be nice to be able to
motivate yourself to get things done
because it's the right thing
and not have to feel those negative
emotions as a result
it just feels like self-flagellation
yeah yeah um i think we can whipping
oneself
yeah i think i think we could say the
same thing about you brought up you know
anger right
so seneca says anything you can
accomplish with anger you can accomplish
with
you know thinking of things through with
reason maybe we can say the same thing
about anxiety if you're relying on
anxiety as your crutch to get you
you know to do what you're supposed to
do or or guilt or whatever
wouldn't it be nicer just to be able to
use reason to do that
and this is something that we're finding
here right now with covid especially if
you're
you're laid off or you're working from
home
you no longer have that office
environment or that boss that's
you know looming over your shoulder in
order to motivate you to actually do the
things that you're
supposedly having to do and if you can
move yourself into oh i want to do this
for its own sake for myself um
that's that's the way that you actually
flourish in that environment you know
yeah it's a lot of it's environmental
that's true yeah
so we have another virtue oriented
question
um somebody was reading the vindication
of the rights of women by mary
wallstonecraft
he says towards the end in chapter 12
wollstonecraft talks about
cruelty as it relates to virtue he says
i really like this particular passage in
our argument in general against cruelty
and here's what
bold stonecraft says this habitual
cruelty is first caught at school where
it is one of the rare sports of the boys
to torment the miserable brutes that
fall in their way
the transition as they grow from
barbarity to brutes to domestic tyranny
over wives children and servants is very
easy justice or even benevolence will
not be a powerful spring of action
unless it extends to the whole creation
nay i believe it may be delivered as an
axiom that those who can see
pain unmoved will soon learn to inflict
it
and then the person says i'm trying to
get a better understanding of the
relationship
between cruelty and virtue in general is
cruelty
the opposite of virtue can one have
virtue and cruelty
can the pursuit of virtue eliminate
cruelty and how damaging is
cruelty to the pursuit of virtue so this
is a very important question we do see a
lot of cruelty
in the world and it's not something we
talk about that much
in ethics but it is something that we
certainly do
react to quite a bit
in response like absolutely it's like
dichotomous i would call cruelty uh a
vicious thing you know
the opposite of virtue and you know we
we translate
uh virtue as excellence and this is the
what is it
what is it excellent to be a a human and
and to directly you know answer
a wilson craft is what is it excellent
to be a human
a man a husband a father in response to
these people that are being cruel
to their contemporaries their wives
their children
and if you know virtue is there to lead
us to a better life especially
where one values you know uh pro social
actions
which are uh usually
we've seen to lead to you know the
betterment of society
um then being cruel is
absolutely vicious the the opposite of
our excellence
or virtue specifically being cruel is
unjust for cruelty is treating someone
worse than that
they themselves deserve yeah that's that
those are all good points
um i'd add that cruelty
in ancient philosophy and running again
through
you know modern times has been called a
vice
and when they're calling it a vice they
aren't just saying it's something bad
they're saying
it's something that becomes part of your
character it becomes dispositional
it becomes a habit so by beginning
with cruelty in one way to say
one set of people eventually you start
becoming cruel to more and more people
and you know i guess you know part of
what's really bad about cruelty is it
doesn't just like
make other people miserable its motive
is to make other people miserable
you know it's to to hurt people to take
things away to humiliate
and seneca actually talks about this in
on
on clemency and on anger where he he
singles out cruelty is a terrible vice
he says
anger's a real big problem cruelty is
even worse than that
you know and i think he's right about
that
people who become cruel and engage in
cruelty eventually come to
view the world and those within it as
either those who are going to be cruel
to them or objects for their own
cruelty and it reminds me of something
that aleister mcintyre
once once said in a conference
the the gist of his remarks were that
you know he was
as as a kid he was beaten for not
learning greek irregular verbs
he went he was in an english school
system and this is a very long time ago
and he said ah you know i i i can read
sophocles and you can't and that was the
joke in it
but then he talked a little bit about
why they stopped doing corporal
punishment
in english schools and it wasn't just
because it was bad for the kids
obviously it was it was
very painful and humiliating and many of
them went on to become bullies
themselves
but it was totally corrupting to the
teachers
because the teachers got to like it
got to like punishing and then they
would seek out occasions
for punishing so totally subverted order
and justice within the classroom you
know
um it stands in the way of so many
things
yep right right yeah it destroys trust
as well
right um so yeah cruelty is uh
it it's it's a vice by itself i guess
you could say in a global way it's
incompatible with
pretty much all of the virtues right so
we we got a
um really general question
is marriage worth it or making a family
no additional explanation uh
answering questions that are that
general you almost got to say well
i don't know is it is it for you you
know what's here what's your situation
so i i'd say very similar i take kind of
the
absurdist thing you know worth it for
whom i find it dependent on the
individuals involved
for many yes for some no is it a good
thing and of itself i take the absurdist
position
of no but it does not matter we are the
ones who give it value
there are however things that one can
only achieve with others and if you
value those things then one ought to
join that group
in this case marriage or family you know
it's it's kind of funny so
when we say is marriage worth it right
what kind of marriage
um if we think about the stereotype
where
like you know um
there's you know the wife doesn't get
along with the mother-in-law
and you know the husband is kind of a
layabout
and all these other back and forth
things like we see in comic strips or um
in in sitcoms or stuff like that maybe
it's not
maybe if that's what marriage really is
then
uh i don't know maybe maybe if if
if i were to picture getting married in
that way then i wouldn't have gotten
married
i think there's there's a lot of
potential goods
that can come out of it if the people
are actually
you know fit to be married to each other
but i mean there's probably some people
who should never be married just because
they're
terrible people or are they they're only
people that work well as hermits
who knows like their best life i was
going to say too is
you know the entire in ancient and
medieval times the entire monastic
uh profession there were a lot of people
who shouldn't have been monks they were
actually in
the middle ages they were called the
oblati if you were like you know
the eighth kid you might get given to
the monastery and they'd be like bring
this kid up as a monk
you're just kind of sol in that but
there were a lot of people who
were attracted to that that lifestyle
some of them actually
who were married and then they're like
listen i want to be done with being
married
i'm going to become a monk how about you
become a nut or vice versa
and sometimes they actually wanted to do
that and
you know why would they want to do that
well you have to have something else
that's drawing you in so in the case of
uh traditional christian monasteries
would be to pray and i don't get close
to god or something in the case of like
buddhist monasteries to meditate and
you know understand emptiness or
whatever whatever it's going to be
but there has to be something
transcendent
i mean it could be just like a hermit
out in nature but then you value nature
right so i guess
the next question would be some of us
feel that we are not fully who we could
be
but what does that mean what does it
mean to be
are humans like rocks and we are and
we are just we all just are we are
yeah is there a specifically human way
to be or could we be
in a way that is the same for rocks gods
platonic ideals and mathematical objects
that's a that's a kind of a a strange
uh miscellaneous drawer to throw
everything into but
yeah um i mean i i kind of interpret
that as
asking about somebody who maybe doesn't
feel like they're
um reaching their potential and that's
often the case for all of us um
but you know you can talk about it as
being sort of a i'm not reaching my
potential in this way over here
or it could be like a you know larger
existential crisis you know what am i
you know that sort of sort of business
neo whoa you know
that isn't where i was i was going with
it uh but yeah i guess you could
you could say that the matrix is a
voyage of self-discovery or something i
mean
it just so happens to find out he's the
hero i mean a real existential
crisis is more about given that you're
not the hero
because you thought you were what value
does your
your life have um so maybe uh
the matrix has seen through like switch
because switch is a really interesting
character
and in the original um
uh script she is
i believe it is the character is um
male but presents themselves as female
when they're in the matrix and that's
the reason that they switch
and they they had to tone that down
because in 1999
that was still weird and you know it
shows the the
kowski sisters you know in their own
transitions like you could see
them writing their their lives and their
experiences into their
characters um but you know she also
dies a rather unceremonious death at the
hands of
um what cipher which you know it's
already an apropos name
it's almost as like on the nose as count
dooku or
darth sidious um yeah
but uh you know maybe as that like this
person
that goes through this massive
transformation and
that because by dint of living in
both the real world and a matrix in
which one can present themselves however
they want
they have the ability to then become
their true selves
um only to have their life just cut
short in
a rather unceremonious and un heroic way
yeah i mean movies only offer you
one vantage point even even like
remember how in the 90s
we do all these movies where there's
like you know four different screens or
like you know
all this non-linear time stuff you're
really still stuck with one
one basic way of looking at things
but there's all these other genres that
that could offer us
greater ways of doing i mean think about
massive multiplayer games
um each person i guess could be the hero
in their own local area but they're not
the
they're not necessarily the the you know
capital t
uh capital h hero
should we take some some other questions
uh
okay so here's one uh in what depth
should a philosophy student study
rhetoric
so it's always a
i know how much and you know
he is asking the right question in what
depth and you know
definitely you need to know enough
rhetoric that you can understand an
argument
and reduce one's
chance of falling into the pitfalls of
fallacious reasoning
but not so much that rhetoric becomes
the master of logic and reason
that way sophistry lies and if you're
you're you you master rhetoric to the
point where
you can make any argument sound good
then you're mooring on what should be
argued
then sometimes comes unmoored
yeah i would actually myself probably be
more receptive to studying rhetoric
but i'm i'm influenced there by
aristotle and cicero both of whom
thought that you need to have this kind
of integration of rhetoric and
philosophy
and so what keeps the rhetoric that you
study at a high level which which
aristotle did and cicero did as well
from turning into sophistry is the
influence of philosophy
like ethics and you know political
theory and stuff like that so you won't
just
use that that great capacity and you
might say well that's a shame you know
you're
you know your opportunities aren't being
taken and your skills are lying fallow
and sister would say well in that case
that that's fine
you know you don't have to make every
argument uh
uh even if it's not a good argument look
good so well
and rhetoric is like a tool and you can
use a sword to defend a city
or you can use a sword to you know be a
uh highwayman and yeah and rob and kill
people for their money on the road
like it's it's in how you utilize it
it's
it is the means to the ends and the ends
or the talos as the
aristotle will put it are the things
that actually matter here
right yeah and some people who are very
good at things sometimes
uh always want to practice that and
aristotle would say no you gotta you
gotta
put it in context let's do the one more
question because we're getting close to
the
uh okay of our show so if individually
you were marooned on a desert
island with one wise person to seek
knowledge from who would you
respectively choose
you can't choose loved ones or life
partners
i was thinking about this and it's like
okay i was like okay
maybe like a happy philosopher because
like i gotta get stuck with him so it's
not just like
deep conversation jumping around yeah
and so like i i don't want nietzsche
he he's just no he was sick all the time
too you know
yeah um and
just kind of doubt i'm just like okay
who's a happy philosopher i'm like
no one's coming to mind and i was like
you know what
with a philosophy is the love of wisdom
and i could definitely apply that
uh definition to the physicist richard
bidenman
who you know won a nobel prize in
physics for his work on
like quantum physics yeah and
and was has his just amazing life
but like the thing that is so intriguing
about him is he goes about everything
with his almost childlike wonder
in the way that he looks at the world
and he'll there's like a story of him
hanging out and they like they break a a
piece of
um spaghetti uncooked spaghetti and it
breaks into three pieces
and the third piece like always breaks
at like a certain ratio of the other two
pieces
and like that's really interesting and
so they just keep on breaking and like
their
their whole night of like oh we're gonna
have a nice dinner together turns into
them just
like investigating
the the most mundane of things that has
no practical use but
it's just that like i'm going to uh dig
into this and you know maybe there was
some
uh principle there i'm not quite sure
that could be applied to something else
and so you don't know until you
actually try so i'm gonna say just very
briefly because we're just about out of
time um
you know it's tough for for a
philosopher to pick who they'd be moored
with or so many cool philosophers i
would take cicero
and i think i would pick him because he
had such an encyclopedia grasp of things
he'd be really interesting to chat with
so uh any final thoughts
you mentioned feynman i think you have
something that you want to bring up
to take us out on well just before we go
i want to once again thank riverwest
radio 104.1 fm lp milwaukee
and you can give donations radio dot com
they're a great organization and so
we'll leave you today with the
words richard feynman nobody ever
figures out
what life is all about and it doesn't
matter explore the world
nearly everything is really interesting
if you get into it deeply enough
[Music]
you